[music]
>> Hi everyone.
I'm Florina Montanescu. I'm
a developer relations engineer working
on lots of things AI both intelligent
experiences what we're going to talk
about today and also developer
productivity. So if you want to talk
about that find me at the booth later
on.
I'm Ollie PM for Android AI.
Our work spans a bit of everything. I've
been working on this since before we
called AI and back when we were calling
it just ML.
So we do a bit of everything from
helping build features, things that run
directly in the OS with applied AI. So
things like background tasks that
optimize the screen brightness and
system memory and everything through to
developer tools and infrastructure to
make it easier for people who are
building features on Android and right
down to the lowest levels of hardware
acceleration and iOS optimization with
many of our silicon partners. So we do a
bit of everything so happy to talk about
any of that as well.
We want to make this a conversation
where you're asking the questions and
then we're trying to answer as many as
possible of them.
But I'm not sure like how familiar you
all are with like what's available on on
Android about how to build intelligent
experiences.
How
Would you raise your hand if you already
know how to build intelligent
experiences on Android with like on
device hybrid or cloud?
Okay, we're going to do a short like
TLDR and then hopefully from there you
might also get some ideas of like what
kind of questions you you want to ask.
Okay, so if you want to build
intelligent experiences on Android you
can use on device models. You can use
hybrid so use on device when on device
is available but otherwise do the
inference on the cloud
or just do cloud inference fully.
So when it comes to building on device
the prompts are processed directly on
the device with no data being sent to
the server.
This is great because of multiple
reasons. It means that you're able to
take advantage of local processing.
So sensitive data like I don't know
banking information doesn't have to
leave the device. You have the ability
to do offline work and of course it
means that there's no additional cost
for all of the inference.
So use cases like you know sensitive
data like or personalization or anything
that requires like maybe a shorter
context window like translations and so
on are things that you can do on device.
So there are two main ways you can do
this in Android. You can use the ML Kit
GenAI APIs where you get access to
Gemini Nano which is our on device model
or if you need something that's much
more customizable your own models your
own custom models then you can use Light
Art LM. There's another talk after this
talking about Light Art LM so we're just
going to talk about the ML Kit GenAI
APIs.
So we said that these are the ones that
give you access to Gemini Nano. So this
is our most efficient models model for
on device tasks and it's using the same
architecture as Gemma 4 that you
probably have heard about that was
launched I think last week but Gemini
Nano is optimized for Android devices.
So the way
Gemini Nano comes on your device is
through the AI Core system service. So
with this it means that you only have
one model on the device and then all of
the apps are using that same model
through this AI Core system.
Because it's
Gemini Nano it means that we're
optimizing for the hardware so you get
like what is it lower latency and
faster execution for AI tasks.
>> Yeah, so you can think about this as you
know imagine you're using a cloud
service, right? And everything is kind
of provided for you. You don't have to
worry about setting up the LLMs, running
them on devices, getting your TPU
inference etc. You just focus on your
feature, your prompt and then the
service provides everything. We're doing
the same thing for on device, right? So
we get the models to the device, we make
sure they're optimized, take advantage
of the specific hardware that's
available on each device at runtime
and sort of make the package that all up
for you so you don't have to worry about
any of that stuff.
And it's also it has privacy and safety
considerations. So this means that you
know your requests are not going to be I
don't know messed up with all of the
other apps requests. They run in
isolation and then the input and the
output data is not stored on device at
all. So it's all as private and secure
as possible.
Okay, so how do you access these
the Gemini Nano? So you do this using
the ML Kit GenAI APIs. So actually
GenAI ML Kit APIs are part of the bigger
ML Kit APIs where you also get access to
APIs and models for like vision and
natural language. For GenAI specifically
we actually have a bunch of APIs
specialized on specific tasks like
summarization, proofreading, rewrite and
so on. But the most powerful of them is
actually the prompt API.
This means that you're able to send
natural language requests to Gemini
Nano.
For now it supports text and image as
input and text only as output.
So with the prompt API it means that you
can easily use it for like stuff like
image understanding,
content assistance, content analysis,
entity extraction. So I would pretty
much say whatever use case you want to
do prompt API is going to be able to
help you.
Okay.
The Gemini Nano models are only
available on like
Pixel 9, Pixel 10 kind of like that
generation of devices not just on Pixel
devices but also on other OEMs.
So what do you do if you want to get
access or be able to use AI on other
devices? Well, you can do this by using
cloud when the local model is not
available for that device. So that
increases the reach of your feature.
So to do this you would use the Firebase
AI logic. We've launched a hybrid
inference
a couple of weeks ago.
So this means that you're able to decide
like if we have Gemini Nano available on
device then you can run that inference
on device. Otherwise it can run on the
cloud and especially now I think with
um
Gemma 4 when the next generation of
Gemini Nano will be available and I
think we can already use it with using
the AI Core preview.
It means that you're able to have the
similar experience using on device with
Gemma Gemini Nano 4 and then also in the
cloud with like the Gemini Flash
models.
But
if you want access to even more powerful
models like the
the Pro Flash Flash Light and you want
to run all of this in the cloud you can
also do this using the Firebase AI
logic. So this gives you access to both
Gemini API and Vertex AI and Gemini
developer API
as providers.
>> Wow.
Okay. That was a whirlwind.
[clears throat]
I'm sorry.
I think this is amazing.
We just wanted to kind of set the scene
because
with Android we're really trying to make
sure there is a comprehensive offering,
right? So everything that you need
whether it's running things locally on
device for low latency responses, for
private inference, whether it's going to
the cloud for almost powerful models,
whether it's something in between
we're building out a solution for you
that covers each of those points and
we're trying to make those APIs as
consistent as possible so that it's easy
for you to blend what is needed. So we
wanted to kind of give you a high level
view of everything
but we're also happy to go super deep on
any of these things. We're happy to talk
about use cases, we're happy to talk
about what we're seeing in the industry,
what we think is interesting, where
we're going but we really just wanted to
set the scene a little bit with some of
the different things we've got available
today.
Florina, anything? Yeah.
What Ollie said. So I think actually now
we're handing it over to all of you.
Okay, Um my main question is like
have you checked
amount of RAM usage or like the battery
consumption that you might have Mhm.
running Gemini Nano models
or Light Art LM?
Yeah,
absolutely. So as Florina mentioned
these models today we've shrunk them
down as much as we could whilst trying
to maintain all that capability. But
that does mean they need flagship
capabilities, right? Right now.
For battery concerns that's one of the
reasons why we've produced AI Core which
is to basically optimize everything as
much as we can so that you can know that
you can rely on that day if it's
available I'm going to be able to use it
and I'm going to get the best
performance out of it. Yes, there is
battery impact. If you are running this
non-stop you are going to run down the
battery fairly quickly.
But what we're finding is that the kinds
of use cases where people are using it
today are things like you know a user is
coming in asking a question and they're
responding or they're manipulating some
data and it's happening at that point in
the flow. Users maybe use it 10, 20
times a day. That sort of usage is
really not you know concerning for
battery life. Where we're seeing more
batch use cases so I have a bunch of
stuff that I want to process
often times that's not necessarily
latency sensitive so people are using
that in the background perhaps when it's
running overcharge overnight and they
can basically run that continuously
until they've completed all their tasks.
But this is one of the reasons why we're
trying to build in the platform so that
we can sort of do all those
optimizations for you so you don't need
to worry about it. If however you have
very specific needs and you want to go
with the custom models we have a bunch
of tools for profiling, for trying to
determine what the impact is going to be
for you but of course it does need you
to do some of that work if you're going
to go custom.
Sorry, can I just give you this hand mic
since you're
>> Just pass that around if you've got a
question. Thank you very much.
Um yeah, quick question regarding two
actually two questions. First one, quick
one.
So, in the in the case of using ML kit,
which is will be outside the most
optimized one, offering,
it means does that mean that we are
using
um
a model that is shared cross apps on
device? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. If yes, then
is
how are we sure is it managing the
scale? Imagine like a user have 100 app
that's actually all
in two years time they will all using
that same model. How are you handling
that to get I would say
latency as good as possible? So, so
that's exactly one of the reasons why
we're doing this at a system level,
right? If you imagine these models,
we're talking about the smallest ones
are like 1 GB to be useful. The ones
we're shipping are actually close to 3-4
GB in total.
It's not really very easy to ship that
as an app developer yourself. It really
requires you to have an absolutely
killer feature to justify that to an end
user. If we put this in the system, we
do that once and everyone can share and
benefit from it, well, that shares that
cost, right? So, that's one of the
reasons why we're doing this. So, we
have no concerns about hundreds of apps
using this because we've centralized
that cost. In terms of lots and lots of
apps using this to generate features,
what we tend to find is that yes, it
does have a battery impact, but by
centralizing that, by queuing things, by
making sure there is some overall system
management, we can inform the user of
like, "By the way, this app is using
quite a lot of quota to do this. Do you
want to do that?" Right? We don't ask
that, but as in we're attributing it to
the battery impact. And we've seen this
time and time again with things like GPS
or Wi-Fi. If the user feels they're
getting value out of the app, they're
very happy to use that. They're happy to
spend their battery on the features they
love. If, however, the app is doing
something that doesn't provide a lot of
value to the user, they might not want
to use that, right? So, we think it's
really important to just make these
capabilities available, make it easy for
you to use them sensibly, and then
developers will build amazing features
and users will choose what they want to
spend their battery on. But from a
developer perspective, you don't need to
worry about that. You just do your
inference and then that's it and then
the AI core does all of the Correct. the
We handle the scheduling, we handle make
sure [clears throat] that you know,
things are getting queued up
appropriately and stuff, so you don't
need to worry about that. So, only the
probably thing to think about is if
there are other apps using that model,
then probably
the our prompt will get in the queue,
basically. So, if you're trying to
obviously access it from the background,
then yes, you'll be queued. If you're in
the foreground, of course, you're going
to have top priority. So, whichever app
is currently being used actively by the
user is obviously going to be
prioritized by the system.
Uh the question in the back.
Android 12 on my phone, which is not a
Pixel, right? It's an Asus, but it
doesn't matter.
And I have used
um the Hold it closer.
>> assistant. Can you hear me better now?
Yeah, great. So, I have a couple of
questions. The first one is
um
when I'm asking Google to do solve
something for me, is it doing locally on
my mobile or is it doing remotely? When
you are when you say when I'm asking
Google,
do you mean like the Gemini app or
Whatever whatever I have on my Android
by default. I did not install anything.
It is there. I just say, "Hey Google,
what's the temperature outside?" And it
will give me an answer. Is it running
this locally or is it running remotely?
So, that would be the Gemini app or like
the search app that has integration with
the Gemini APIs. To be honest, I'm not
sure. My expectation would be that it's
running this remote. Right. So, then my
next question makes a lot more sense.
How can I then install the things that
you have presented here? And and second
part to this, is it possible to write
skills to for it to locally to improve
the kind of answers that it gives me? If
I notice that it's giving me
consistently the wrong answers for
whatever reason, possible to do that?
So, what you're talking about is like
two different
user journeys. Cuz if you're building
your own app, you wouldn't interact with
the Gemini app. That's a completely
different app, but rather you would
interact with the model itself. Yes.
Therefore, if you're using an on-device
model, you don't need to care about the
the cloud. All of that inference will be
on device. Yes.
So, I'm asking precisely about that. If
I installed what you showed here
locally, assuming it is possible, Yeah,
yeah, yeah. and I then write write
skills to improve the kind of responses
it gives me? I don't think you would
write the skills.
No, so I mean it depends on the kind of
experience you're trying to build,
right? But if you think about a skill,
it's just something you're sticking into
the prompt alongside the rest of your
query. So, the tools we're providing
here are more sort of low-level and
designed for you to be able to build
back on top of that, right? So, if for
example, you went and installed
something like Pocket Claw or Open Claw
on the phone itself, that would then
basically take those skills, compose
them into a prompt, which it would run
through this API.
So, what we're focusing on here is
building the lower layers to enable you
or others to build those things on top.
Thank you.
5 minutes.
We started late.
Uh
there was one question there.
Yeah. So, the Gemini Nano model itself
is completely contained by AI Core,
right? So, you don't need to worry about
how to set that up and configure it. You
use the APIs to access it and it's all
handled by the system. In terms of
building a RAG-like solution, yes,
absolutely, you can do that with the
Prompt API.
We are looking at extending some of the
APIs we have, for example, adding an
embedding API soon, and that will make
it easier for building these kind of
RAG-like solutions. But yes, it's
totally possible to do that. In terms of
the relationship between AI Edge Gallery
and AI Core, AI Edge Gallery is a
showcase to show you what's possible,
right? You can use AI Core backing in
that or you can use custom models. We
really want you to see the full breadth
of things you can do.
AI Edge Gallery, I think, is a really
good way of showing the frontier of what
you can do, right? But it requires more
uplift. There's more work you have to do
to take advantage of those things. AI
Core is really focused on making it easy
for you to just focus on the prompt,
focus on the specific feature rather
than any of the setup. Build like
production-level apps.
When you say system, do you mean like
system prompts or files? So, Like I have
to take a lot of pictures today. Yeah. I
want to then
like summarize everything together. Mhm.
Make a note. Yeah. So, the ML Kit
GenAI API, the Prompt API, allows both
text and image input. So, you can give
it access, yeah. So, all the things your
app normally has access to in terms of
files and so on, you can then obviously
pass them through the API
and run them just like just like you
would do on a server-based inference,
right? In terms of creating the prompt,
feeding the information in.
Is there any vectorizing embedding model
also available for this API? Like I want
to vectorize some of my text notes so
that they're like, you know, I can get
similarity between some other notes,
maybe. So, does this have that or So, we
don't yet have an embedding API. We will
soon. Cool. So, if you're looking at
things like the Gemini embedding model,
that's what we're going to make
available so that you can use that
directly from the API.
You want a last question? Last question.
We're being kicked out. Thanks.
Yeah, there's a diversity of devices,
you know,
and there's also a diversity of models.
You showed the Prompt API and you know,
embeddings are coming soon, but how do I
think about the sort of that matrix of
device, like what's capable on a given
device versus like what what models can
be used? You know, there are more
use cases than just LLM and embedding
model or are there other models that
also run on device?
And then
will they be widespread across all
devices or do I need the latest
flagships to to use those? So, as Ferrie
showed, the ML Kit API covers a range of
things, like text, OCR, vision, all
sorts of stuff. Those models, the
classical models, are much smaller. They
can run on super large range of devices,
like billion plus devices, no problem.
The new ones, the GenAI APIs, those ones
require currently fairly flagship
devices from the last couple of years.
What we're doing with AI Core is we
package that up and say, "Hey, you can
call this API and if it's available, you
know it's going to run well."
If, however, that reach is not big
enough for you and you want to basically
do the work to test on a wider range of
devices, Light RT LM, which Cormac is
going to talk about in a second, can
help you do that, but you will then need
to do the work for testing. Cormac
hopefully will talk about some of these
tools we have available to make it
easier to do that testing, but you will
need to do that testing yourself. For AI
Core, we cover that all, so you know
that if it's covered by AI Core, it's
going to run well.
We're going to be around today and
tomorrow, so please come and ask us
questions. Thank you.
>> [music]